bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce bloc 3 où je vais vous
accompagner en face caméra et en voix
off
tout au long des images que vous allez
voir parce que je vous emmène en
randonnée dans deux départements la
lozère puis le larzac où j'ai donc filmé
pendant les randonnées et comment vous
dire
les enregistrements sonores étaient
vraiment pas bon tout simplement parce
que je suis pas parti avec un micro
externe dans le sac à dos pour m'éviter
du poids supplémentaire et donc il y
avait énormément de vent parce qu'on
était sur des hauts plateaux et c'est
franchement pas folichon donc je préfère
commenter ici les images que vous allez
voir et puis à la fin du blog là pour le
coup ce sera format blog classique où
c'était un autre jour il y avait
quasiment pas de vent et vous
m'entendrez très bien
la première chose qu'on est allé voir
c'est une enceinte protohistorique sur
le causse méjean
donc c'est en lozère alors une enceinte
protohistorique qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une construction à but défensif
qui est une sorte d'enclos muret qui
datent donc de la protohistoire la
protohistoire c'est alors là en
particulier cette enceinte
protohistorique elle date de la tène
donc c'est à peu près le ivème siècle
avant jésus-christ une enceinte
protohistorique elle a deux fonctions
principales
la première est les défensives c'est à
dire que au centre de cette enceinte est
bien il ya des îlots d'habitation que
qu'on ne voit plus aujourd'hui je
pourrais pas vous les montrer et à
l'extérieur on mettait les espaces
funéraire donc les endroits où on
inhument les morts
cette fonction défensive eh ben elle est
renforcée par l'endroit où se situe
l'enceinte c'est à dire sur un plan
culminant on a donc une vue globale du
causse méjean et on peut se protéger des
envahisseurs et enfin la dernière
fonction de ces enceintes
elle peut être aussi esthétique c'est à
dire que ça peut être agréable pour les
habitants d'habiter sur un point
dominant qui vous offre une vue
spectaculaire
pour vous donner une idée de la taille
de 7
de cette enceinte je crois qu'elle fait
150 mètres de diamètre ce qui est assez
vaste et d'ailleurs vous pouvez la voir
sur google earth je vous mettrai les
coordonnées en barre d'infos ou jouffre
est une capture écran de de l'affichage
vous pouvez donc voir l'enceinte cette
forme circulaire qui se dessine dans le
paysage est alors cette l'enceinte ce
mur au départ il estimé à 4 mètres de
hauteur et nous ce qu'on a vu on voyait
au maximum 2 mètres de hauteur dont
klépierre qui manquent
elles ont été tout simplement récupéré
par les habitants les bergers depuis bas
depuis des des siècles et des siècles
pour d'autres constructions cette
enceinte elle s'appelle l'ancien
protohistorique de la rode et l'accès
est assez facile en fait il faut prendre
un gr qui part du village qui s'appelle
dry gaou dry gas je sais pas vraiment
comment on prononce ce village et vous
avez quelques kilomètres et même vous
pouvez faire une grande balade une sorte
de boucle qui fait une dizaine de
kilomètres et qui vous fait passer par
cette enceinte
ensuite on a quitté la lozère et on est
parti dans le larzac
toujours pour faire des randonnées c'est
quelque chose qu'on aime beaucoup faire
moi et mon compagnon et ça nous a permis
de découvrir d'autres sites
archéologiques notamment des dolmens et
un site de l'antiquité donc bien plus
récents
alors avant de vous parler un peu plus
de ces découvertes de vous les montrer
ce ses blogs là ça me permet de rappeler
quelque chose qui est très important en
archéologie et qu'on a tendance à
oublier ou tout simplement à ne pas le
prendre en compte
c'est tout ce qui touche à la
prospection la prospection c'est une
grosse partie du boulot des archéologues
c'est à dire que entre les fouilles de
terrain qui se passe souvent l'été et
les rédaction de rapports de fouilles
qui se déroulent le plus souvent l'hiver
est bien les archéologues prospects
prospecter ça veut dire marché aller sur
le terrain essayer de découvrir des
futurs lieux de fouilles et donc moi
massé vlog sauvage
j'ai envie de plus en plus de les
orienter vers des vlog découvertes
archéologiques parce que ça fait partie
de ma formation
ça fait partie de ce que j'aime faire
c'est-à-dire randonnée et avec des
outils google earth des gps et des
cartes ign trouver des sites
archéologiques
j'espère que ainsi vous pouvez
comprendre que l'archéologie c'est pas
forcément des sites touristiques ou
l'entrée est payante avec un fascicule
qu'on vous donne à l'entrée mais que
vous pouvez tout simplement découvrir
des sites en marchant parce que des
sites archéologiques y en a partout
partout sous vos pieds dans les
montagnes il suffit juste de chercher
donc ensuite au larzac on allait voir de
dolmens et un oppidum donc les dolmens
il était très intéressant pour
différentes raisons
le premier c'était intéressant parce que
on pouvait voir encore l'emprise du kern
le kern c'est le tas de pierres qui
recouvre la chambre et bien souvent on a
en mémoire seulement les grandes halles
mégalithique qui font la chambre
funéraire est bien celui ci on pouvait
voir au sol vous voyez il ya des pierres
et puis un endroit elle s'arrête et on
retrouve l'herbe et bien ça ça nous
donne une idée de l'emprise de la taille
originelle de ce monument après un peu
plus loin on est allé voir un autre
domaine qui doit dater à peu près de la
même époque je sais pas précisément mais
du
je dirais 3000 avant jésus-christ qui
lui al'inverse n'avait plus du tout les
pierres du kern c'est à dire que toutes
les pierres ont été pillés récupéré par
les bergers par les habitants pour les
enclos des brebis ou pour des
constructions des maisons dans les
villages
alors ces deux domaines si ça vous
intéresse si vous voulez allez voir ils
sont du côté de la cavalerie c'est le
nom du village qui le long de la grande
deux fois deux voies qui part de millau
ensuite on est donc allé voir un oppidum
est donc là je vous laisse avec les
images qui suivent parce que les
conditions météorologiques étaient
meilleures que les autres jours et on
entend très bien et au moins on retrouve
on a un format blog classique
[Musique]
à
là on vient d'arriver sur le site de
l'oppidum
je vais me mettre à l'abri du vent pour
pouvoir vous expliquer un petit peu ce
que c'est a déjà un oppidum n'y a pas de
vent alors un oppidum c'est le nom que
donne et les romains au ville gauloise
et donc oppidum c'est un oppidum des
oppida c'est à dire ville fortifiée et
donc ça peut comprendre des des sites
immense comme on en a en auvergne à à
bibracte qui est donc un oppidum qui est
situé sur le mont beuvray
là c'est vraiment immense et d'ailleurs
je vois qu'il ya toujours des fouilles
en cours depuis depuis des années et ça
peut être aussi des des structures
beaucoup plus réduite comme ça à l'air
d'être le cas ici mais à des choses
assez intéressantes alors y avait un
petit panneau explicatif qui nous dit
donc que j'associais l'oppidum de la
gran aide et donc il ya trois phases
d'occupation qu'on voit bien dans sur
les restes sur les restes des murailles
il ya un premier première occupation en
mille avant jésus-christ donc là c'est
vraiment de la protohistoire ensuite on
a une occupation au 2e et 1er siècle
avant jésus-christ donc là c'est
vraiment la conquête romaine et ça se
voit très bien sûr au niveau de l'
architecture et après on a une dernière
occupation au bas-empire donc c'est
ivème siècle après jésus-christ et ça
par contre j'y arrive pas on n'arrive
pas à le voir la sueur sur les restes
sur les vestiges mais on va descendre là
je suis vraiment au dessus de la
muraille et on va descendre je vais vous
montrer sur les sur les murs comment on
peut voir ça
[Musique]
ok donc là on voit c'est ça qui est
intéressant
on voit bien les trois phases par au
moins les deux phases de construction on
a un premier premières constructions en
très gros appareil en très gros blocs de
pierre qui a pas du tout la même
inclinaison que ce qui a au dessus et au
dessus c'est la deuxième phase donc là
c'est vraiment époque romaine on voit
bien parce que c'est des pierres plus
petit et qui sont construites en ligne
c'est hyper régulier ça c'est typique de
la construction romaine est la dernière
chose dont classé 2e 1er siècle avant
jésus-christ au dessus on a ce que moi
j'appelle de la callas cdu gravats parce
qu'en fait la construction romaine c'est
du parement c'est des belles pierres en
apparence et c'est un caisson est à
l'intérieur vous venez mettre des
pierres de mauvaise qualité pour remplir
votre mur et c'est vraiment c'est un
super bel exemple d'architecturé on voit
bien les différentes phases le dernier
stade moi je n'arrive pas à le lire là
je sais pas je sais pas vraiment où est
ce qu'on peut bien devoir et le dernier
truc que je voulais vous montrer ce sont
deux gouttière qui sont ici là on est
donc à l'angle de la je vous ai parlé
j'étais pas ici ce sont les deux gouttes
hier deux blocs ici qui sont d'ailleurs
pas au bout d'une espèce de je sais pas
si c'était une voie d'accès ici donc ça
ce sont des pierres qui sont creusés par
la main de l'homme et puis s'est
accentué par le passage de l'eau et donc
ça vient récupérer les eaux de pluie
on voit bien dans l'allée cupules ou et
récupérez l'eau et donc le site est bien
là il continue en fait on monte alors
sur le panneau il explique qu'il ya
différentes voies d'accès qu'ils ont
retrouvé et qui permettait d'avoir les
échanges commerciaux avec millau et à
millau il ya deux rues qui sont de ruz
actuels qui sont en fait fait sur les
anciennes voies romaines et est donc
c'est ainsi qu'il a ses vastes qui est
en hauteur avec un superbe panorama au
bout et c'est hyper propres fins
et encore un peu de rubalise ya encore
le sais pas c'était lancer une remorque
je sais pas du tout quand est-ce qu'ils
ont fouillé ça ça doit être assez
anciens la fouille mais ça vaut le coup
aux marchés un petit peu on a marché
j'ai pas de kilomètres à peu près pour y
accéder et là je vous emmène au au point
culminant avec un superbe panorama
évidemment et un gros gros nuage depuis
on va voir si ça rend quelque chose un
peu de ces rames qui a été découverte
apparemment lassé de la cie gillet qui
est donc produite sur un atelier qui
emballe à millau s'appelle la grosse
banque et qui voit là produit ce type de
céramiques très fine avec un van gogh
c'est ce qu'ont c'est là l'aspect
mangobo rouge avec un aspect dernier
c'est comme si on avait passé un vernis
sabri un peu et ça c'est des poteries
qu'on reconnaît très très facilement
voilà parfois on peut mettre un petit
stand up blanc pour pour décorer assez
chouette
[Musique]
la l'oppidum ce que je vous ai montré
les remparts c'est ici millau et à
droite et donc on voit bien que la
falaise
ça crée un rempart naturel et ça permet
de se défendre
[Musique]
ça c'est de la seram ma part tout pas
on va terminer ce blog ici nous rentrons
à toulouse capitale
j'espère que ces blogs archéo plaide
j'aimerais bien en faire un peu plus
donc c'est un petit peu un test celui ci
plus hésiter pas un bien dans les
commentaires si vous ça vous a plu
et puis on continue à nous emmener dans
des coins comme ça que je connais pas
moi même et je découvre en même temps
que vous au final voilà prenez soin de
vous à la prochaine salut
[Musique]